si está embarazada puede tomar ácido
fólico para ayudar a prevenir
determinados defectos congénitos en su
bebé
el ácido fólico y folato son dos formas
de la misma vitamina b
el folato es la forma que surge
naturalmente en los alimentos mientras
que el ácido fólico es la forma hecha
por el hombre agregada a las
multivitaminas y alimentos fortificados
su organismo necesita ácido fólico para
ayudar a preparar nuevas células
incluso neuronas
glóbulos
y adn en el material genético dentro de
sus células durante el embarazo necesita
aún más ácido fólico porque su bebé
también lo necesita el ácido fólico
ayuda al desarrollo normal de la médula
espinal y del cerebro de su bebé
el consumir ácido fólico puede reducir
significativamente el riesgo de defectos
del tubo neural en su bebé en desarrollo
al que se le llama embrión en esta etapa
el tubo neural comienza con una pequeña
pieza ovalada de tejido embrionario que
se pliega en un tubo aproximadamente 28
días posteriores a la concepción cuando
este tubo se cierra adecuadamente sigue
su desarrollo en el cerebro y médula
espinal de su bebé si el tubo neural no
se cierra por falta de ácido fólico en
su dieta su bebé puede tener un defecto
del tubo neural tal como espina bífida o
anencefalia en el caso de espina bífida
el tubo neural no se cierra en la parte
inferior como resultado las partes de la
espina que encierran y protegen la
médula espinal inferior no se forman por
completo
los niños con este defecto a veces
requieren de cirugía y tienen
discapacidades permanentes incluso
parálisis de piernas retrasos en el
desarrollo y problemas del sistema
nervioso
en el caso de la afección anencefalia el
tubo neural no se cierra en la parte
superior lo que evita que grandes partes
del cerebro y el cráneo se desarrollen
por completo los bebés con este defecto
no pueden vivir y en general se mueren
antes del nacimiento o inmediatamente
después el ácido fólico ayuda también a
proteger contra otros defectos
congénitos como labio leporino y paladar
hendido y el defecto del septo auricular
que es cuando no se cierra una cavidad
entre las cámaras superiores izquierdas
y derechas del corazón durante el
desarrollo debido a que el tubo neural
se desarrolla de forma temprana en el
embarazo a veces antes de que una mujer
sepa que está embarazada los expertos
recomiendan que todas las mujeres en
edad fértil tomen un multivitamínico que
contenga 400 microgramos de ácido fólico
todos los días durante el embarazo la
necesidad aumenta a 600 microgramos de
ácido fólico por día los expertos
recomiendan que tome este
multivitamínico además del folato que
viene en los alimentos en su dieta
porque su organismo no absorbe el folato
que se encuentra natural
en los alimentos tan fácilmente como el
ácido fólico hecho por el hombre los
cuidadores a veces recetan 1000
microgramos de ácido fólico al día para
garantizar que se cubren estos niveles
mínimos incluso se puede necesitar más
en algunos grupos de mujeres incluso en
aquellas con abortos espontáneos previos
en aquellas mujeres con poca enzima
metabólica de ácido fólico hablé con su
cuidador sobre la dosis óptima para
usted